our correspondent and occasional guest
host Luke Beasley whose YouTube channel
you can find at davidpackman.com Luke
was on the ground at the very very
disturbing Trump rally in Waco Texas
over the weekend Luke spoke to a number
of people the topics were wide-ranging
they included gay marriage they included
crisis actors at Sandy Hook it is 2023
don't adjust your TV screen
um it included philosophical questions
about how do we really know anything and
it also included of course George Soros
let's start with the topic of gay
marriage here is Luke inquiring to a
gentleman and I'm using that term
loosely uh about gay marriage let's
listen so what what's inherently more
about gay marriage
anti-life kids and the marriages do you
think it should be illegal for two
straight people who decide not to have
kids to get married no I believe they
should still get married but then that's
anti-life right
it is not anti-life in the same way but
they're not reproducing just like two
gay people don't reproduce
whoa I get what you're saying basically
are you talking about people who know
they're infertile and yet they want to
get married is that what you're saying
any example of that one too you're
saying ban infernal people from getting
married even straight couples
no because at the end of the day they
can still adopt kids and raise them gay
people can adopt kids right I don't
believe they should there's no recent
reports about a gay club this is what
you call just ping-ponging from one
topic to another gay people shouldn't
get married because they can't produce
kids neither can infertile couples and
also some couples don't want to have
kids well but they should be able to get
married because they can adopt but gay
people can also adopt well but gay
people shouldn't be allowed to adopt
this is you you really can't good for
Luke but you really can't talk to these
folks people that is known to abuse
their kids look up the stats I can find
you about 13 gazillion examples of
straight couples abusing their kids yeah
so then he goes to the child abuse meme
um this is what it was this it's
everywhere this stuff is everywhere at
these rallies it doesn't make any sense
here's a guy who's wearing an Alex Jones
was right t-shirt who repeats a lot of
the Sandy Hook conspiracies from more
than a decade ago that even Alex Jones
has since recanted although you could
argue Alex Jones recanted only for legal
reasons but okay let's take a listen to
this one so you're saying you don't
think Sandy Hook parents were actually
being harassed and they had to move on
which you can see they actually had to
do that pardon me these parents are just
lying
I think that uh do I think they're lying
man the question is are the are the
Sandy Hook parents lying that they were
being harassed I really
I really want to answer that question
man because I don't really by the way
it's just so everybody knows this guy's
a Christian okay oh no I don't know if
they're lying you know
my point is when I see a parent crying
because their kid got murdered in a mass
shooting
my first instinct is to trust them and
not the guy who makes money lying about
them what about what about I mean I I do
believe that there was people that was
uh what they what I guess they call uh
uh there's some some crisis actors I
mean how do you explain that the crisis
actors
see this is a very interesting moment
how do you explain that there were
crisis actors what are you talking about
that's not you're assuming something
that you haven't actually demonstrated
and they were caught in certain
different places I mean they were in the
same place how do you explain that
government
I don't trust the government but I trust
the fact okay what are the facts the
facts are that
parents lost their children and then a
man by the name of Alex Jones lied about
that and said there was Crisis actors in
fact
or something because you know what I
believe I believe the only reason it
they're doing this is because they're
gonna they've got to take him down right
it's all a conspiracy to take Alex Jones
down over things Alex Jones chose to say
has since recanted and which we know not
to be true well it seems like a pretty
big unforced error then we went to a
woman who was uh very confused visibly
confused I would even say about why
Trump would be arrested this is pretty
interesting because it gets very
philosophical how do we know anything
how can anything be proven in a court of
law well I don't even know who's Ellen
bragging uh he's the Manhattan district
attorney and he's seems to be reportedly
considering arresting Trump
money payment
store meeting so how can they prove that
that was actually occurred see that's
the whole thing where it comes down to
how do we know it is true what is real
and that's where everything in this
tattoo comes down to a spiritual reality
so her view is it's impossible to
ascertain Truth at all so all we can do
is find a religion to follow which
simply tells us what is true pretty
convenient I have to say if it works for
you I can see why that would be much
more satisfying and pleasing than
understanding the chaos of the real
world the only way you can know it is
true is to believe that there's absolute
truth do
ah you know the reason America is having
a problem is because we need to get back
to God can I ask a quick question so if
it's not like
evidence here you and I can look at okay
is this something that occurred how do
we feel about
instead is a spiritual decision to
understand truth right how do you and I
come to some understanding of uh one
reality if my spiritual truth is
different good who's evil I'm saying
good and evil I'm saying of my spiritual
like if spiritually I were to feel that
Trump is bad because of his
the anti-democratic views or actions he
took as president and then you
spiritually felt he was good how would
we come to some sort of agreement or
even understand each other's side if
it's not based on kind of empirical
information
well that's a whole big you could call
it a hurricane of a conversation that I
would love to get into all the nitties
and gritties of it but probably not
between here
all right yeah so anyway how do we know
anything is really the question and
that's where religion comes in for this
woman but of course it's like which
religion you've got a thousand religions
and they very often conflict with each
other uh Luke then spoke to the first
guy to raise the topic of George Soros
and Luke's pretty slick here in the
questions he's asking sort of trying to
get at the anti-semitic undertones of
all of this the guy kinda Dodges it a
little take a look at this look at who's
running the country our borders are free
to come and go
which are who
Soros George stores media in general
yeah why is it they use that particular
term puppeteers in relation to Soros
because uh uh he has enough money he can
buy anybody he uh how much money has he
given to Joe Biden
I have no idea
and there it is and you know he's
controlling him because that's what I
read That's What I Hear and you leave
the election story
no don't no
no I mean I believe that there are
people probably voted more often than
they should you know and I believe
there's a lot of people who were not
registered that did vote but how do you
vote if you're not registered it's never
clear but I think
I don't
I don't get your evidence all the other
people here right which in that
particular crowd there's a noticeable
lack of evidence I'm glad the guy is
identifying that there's none yeah oh my
gosh okay
don't you feel it's pretty dangerous to
say the election Stone if you don't have
evidence
you're right I'm saying sorry I meant to
specify Trump because he says a lot well
the fingers when you're got that much
money and stuff you can sweep a lot of
things under the rug until the rug's too
full right and answers but if you don't
you have evidence I could say anything
about anything you're a murderer I don't
have an Evidence but you could have
sweep down the road you know what I mean
yeah that's right when you're a
politician you're just sitting there as
a target for anybody who wants to accuse
you of anything
this is if you're confused by what this
guy's saying that's the right reaction
don't you think it's dangerous for
people's belief in the legitimacy of our
democracy to say it was stolen it
doesn't work anymore without solid
evidence
yeah
he agrees it's extremely dangerous what
he's doing so then for me I would have a
really hard time even if I like other
policies supporting a political leader
if the most important part of our
political process are democratic
institutions and process is being uh
kind of assaulted by his rhetoric yeah I
think he talks too much okay so anyway
yeah Trump probably shouldn't be saying
that the guy says same guy here with
another woman I think this might be his
wife but I don't know apparently his
wife doesn't believe January 6th is
really a big deal that should even
really be talked about very much
Trump rallies where they start turning
cars over and burning them
oh my God
did we just talk about we're not
fighting yeah
we believe what do we believe about
January 6th it's all the media okay it's
just a media story it's not even real
years ago yeah why do they keep bringing
up and rehashing in different ways I can
tell you because it was an attempt to
subvert the world of people and block
the certification of a president who got
elected
no see the guys it's that simple why
bother learning about things just do
what this woman says you just say no it
was an attempt to subvert the will of
the people and install a president who
didn't actually win no wow that's a
pretty good argument ma'am I have to say
uh and then last clip here here's a
woman who believes Trump won but she's
very confused what makes you believe
Trump won
because he has the majority of people
even though the official vote counts
don't show that okay now did you notice
that she says look around here
there are 3 500 people here in Waco
Texas who support Trump clearly that
proves that a country of 330 million
voted for him
fraud what people did
were you saying looking around here
helps you to see the majorities with
Trump
so we usually we love president Trump
the American people love America here's
kind of an analogy
do you know who Taylor Swift is
the pop artist yeah so I've gone she's
she's great I've gone to one of her
concerts before and it's this massive
Stadium probably three four times the
amount of people who will be at this
event there to see Taylor Swift and so
there it would seem like everyone knows
and loves Taylor Swift but we understand
if you polled Americans it probably
wouldn't be a majority who are fans of
Taylor Swift and so that kind of gives
you a sense of
when you're within a public and see
everyone good for Luke he's trying but
it's not getting through loves a
particular thing or is a fan of a
particular person when in reality the
broader world doesn't actually match
that
and so we have to look at things like
data empirical information such as our
election results to understand what the
actual majority wants
he won Bayern Square
[Laughter]
I mean that's pretty convincing he got
the majority he we love he didn't even
get the majority of the popular vote Pam
is the American people he has stood for
Israel he has stood for The Unborn he
doesn't drink
right he has good morals he has good
kids he has good grandkids and we are
blessed to have him
the president of the United States
hard to uh hard to argue against folks
who don't actually care about reality
but they care about I don't know it
looks like people here like them it
seems pretty good to me really nice job
by Luke and and a range of topics a
range of people really good stuff and
we'll have all of these clips if you're
just listening today you want to see
what the the whole scene is like
visually and I do recommend that we'll
have these clips up on our YouTube
channel youtube.com the davidpackman
show and we'll also have them on our
Instagram and on Tick Tock these clips
are going to be everywhere believe me
imagine for a second that you try
logging into your email account only to
find that your password was changed an
hour ago and then you get notifications
of activity from your bank and then your
credit cards that is what identity theft
is like and it's a horrible feeling and
we dealt with it at the show not that
long ago but now I have an app called
Aura which gives me much more peace of
mind our sponsor Aura is the all-in-one
solution for keeping your online account
safe because Aura will scan the dark web
for your personal info passwords social
security number and you get fast alerts
when they find something you also get
fast alerts about credit inquiries Aura
protects all of your devices from
malware or even requests the removal of
your info from data broker sites and
Aura helps you manage what your kids can
do on their devices you can restrict
certain apps set screen time limits set
Focus times when you need them off of
devices is go to aura.com Pacman to try
it free for seven days your login
credentials might already be floating
around out there and Aura will tell you
instantly for free the link is down
below